to optimize the CSS on construction we
want to remove unnecessary styles minify
compress and cache it is that right yep
those are all good ones but if I
remember correctly I think when you run
PageSpeed on your site you're also
recommended that we look into render
blocking CSS oh yeah what's that about
well let's take a look let's say we have
a simple page with one CSS file the
browser downloads the HTML and then
discovers and fetches the CSS what is
the earliest point where the browser
could paint a page is that a once the
browser has built a Dom or is it B once
the browser has downloaded the CSS and
built the CSS object model